لا تقم بعمل سيناريو أو سكرابل، قابل
روبي البالغة من العمر أربع سنوات ولكن لا تطلب منها أن
تبتسم، ابتسامتك جميلة، أوه، لقد
حاولت أخت روبي سبيكلر الجميلة وصديق أختها إعطاء
روبي برنامجًا تعليميًا حول كيفية الابتسام، والآن افعل ذلك
بأسنانك.
لا،
لا، فقط استمر في ذلك، لا تقبض أنفك،
لا تفعل ذلك بهذه الطريقة،
افرد أنفك وابتسم في الواقع
وكأن الفيديو لأعلى، انتشر الفيديو على نطاق واسع مما
تسبب في ابتسامة الملايين من الأشخاص ولكن
ليس روبي كما لو كنت سعيدًا،
تقول أخت روبي إنها لاحظت أولًا ما
إنها تسمي الابتسامة المزعجة عندما
التقطوا بعض الصور العائلية، لقد جعلت هذا الأمر
فظيعًا مثل الوجه المبتسم ذو الذقن المزدوجة
الذي لا يبدو أنها
سعيدة على الإطلاق، إنه شيء
يجده الآباء في كل مكان رائعًا، كل طفل يمر
بابتسامة تشاندلر
بينج من الأصدقاء الذين يحاولون  ابتسم من أجل
صور الخطوبة الآن، تشاندلر، تريد
أن تبتسم لنا،
حسنًا،
لم يحاول أصدقاء روبي وعائلتها أن
يجعلوها تقول الجبن، لقد وضعوها
أمام المرآة، شيء واحد فقط
نجح، وهو دغدغتها أحيانًا للحصول على
ابتسامة جيدة  ربما
تجد صعوبة في الابتسام عند
الأمر، لكنها أتقنت لفت النظر
وانتظر حتى ترى
سكاوت الغاضب لأنك لن تستمع إلى
جدتي، يمكن أن تبدو روبي أحيانًا وكأنها
رمز تعبيري متجهم ينبض
بالحياة.  Grumpy Cat رأيتها
تنادي نعم، هذا قريب جدًا بحيث
يضرب الظفر على رأسها انظر إلى تلك
العبوس الثاقب أصبحت Grumpy Cat ميمًا
استمتعت بها عندما كانت فظيعة على الأقل لم
يضطر أحد على الإطلاق إلى إخبار روبي بمسح تلك
الابتسامة عن وجهها  اقلب هذا العبوس
رأسًا على عقب جيني ماوس سي إن إن نيويورك
احتفل بأي شخص